de
commission monsieur le ministre le
président Laffond et moi-même et ainsi
que l'ensemble des collègues sommes
ravis de vous accueillir cet après-midi
dans le cadre de la mission qui est la
nôtre qui est une mission conjointe
commission des lois
Affaires Culturelles éducation et et
sport sur quiortême le traitement la
pression les menaces les agressions dont
les enseignants sont victimes c'est
chacun l'a bien
compris la suite de l'affaire de
Monsieur Samuel Bti et puis les
circonstances qui qui démontre à
l'évidence queil y a bien de difficulté
nous
[Musique]
sommes avec vous dans l'idée d'aborder
les sujets naturellement de nos
fonctionnaires d' l'éducation nationale
alors de tous les fonctionnaires mais
singulièrement ceux de l'éducation
nationale qui sont pris sous cette sous
cette pression sous les menaces en tous
les cas dans un climat de travail qui
n'est pas rassurant ni pour eux ni pour
nous d'ailleurs mais d'abord pas pour
eux et donc nous avons le souhait
d'aborder avec vous le travail que vous
avez peut-être pu engager ou que vous
avez engagé pour leur assurer d'une part
une protection fonctionnelle sans doute
renforcé dans certaines circonstances
mais de voir de quelle
façon nous nous pouvons vousf le
gouvernementctement nous collectivement
quand même nous pouvons leur apporter un
soutien et comprendre ce qui est fait et
voir éventuellement ce qui pourrait être
fait demain cont tenu des circonstances
j'indique que nous sommes retr en direct
sur le site internet du du Sénat mais je
vous a dit monsieur le ministre que
étant siégeant sous forme de commission
d'enquête vous avez donc l'obligation de
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité Nant et toute la
vérité je vous rappelle les dispositions
du les articles du Code pénal qui
régissent cette situation
434-13-1 ET-1 du code pénal je vous
invite donc monsieur le ministre avant
de de prendre la parole prêter serment
et et de dire effectivement toute la
vérité rien que la vérité en levant la
main droite et en disant je le jure je
m'engage donc à dire toute la
véritéé je le jure monsieur le présid
merci monsieur le ministre je sais pas
si le président la fond veut la parole
tout a été dit par le président buffet
donc voilà donc vous avez la parole
monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup messieurs les
les présidents Mesdames et Messieurs les
les sénateurs et et je
vrais remercier à la fois la commission
des affaires culturelles et la
commission des lois d'avoir
bien voulu me recevoir aujourd'hui et et
m'entendre la mission de contrôle que
vous effectuez je crois est évidemment
lié à des actualités dramatiques et je
le dis en ayant une pensée évidemment
pour la famille de de Dominique Bernard
et suite au drame
d'aras et au-delà sur les agressions les
menaces et parfois les le pire
c'est-à-dire des assassinats que vivent
nos agents publics dans l'ensemble des
services publics et j'élargis en en
introduisant cette cette commission mon
propos aux agents publics qui ces
derniers mois et sur cette année ont été
assassinés dans l'exercice de leur
fonction je pense à Agnès LAL professeur
à Saint-Jean de luuse assassiné dans
l'exercice des ses fonctions je pense à
Ludovique Montuel agent de la DG FIP et
à sa collègue qui a été séquestré de Vic
Montuel a été assassiné dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions je pense à Karen mzino
infirmire
à l'hôpital à mes qui a elle aussi été
assassinée dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions et au-delà de de ces agents
publics assassiné je crois que la
situation elle concerne en réalité des
milliers des dizaines de milliers
d'agents publics qui sont
quotidiennement menacé agressés
violentés dans tous les lieux de service
public derrière tous les guichet de
service public
et j'ai souhaité m'engager de de façon
très transversale au fond parce que je
crois que quand parfois nous sommes
réunis pour parler d'attractivité de la
fonction publique pour parler de son
efficacité je crois que la la première
considération au fond qu'on doit aux
agents publics c'est de les mettre dans
les bonnes situations pour exercer leur
mission et donc l'enjeu de protection de
protection physique c'est un enjeu qui
est absolument central et qui doit nous
mobiliser absolument et donc je voudrais
dans dans mon propos avoir une approche
transversale qui souhaite que celle que
j'ai souhaité installer dans toutes les
administrations elle doit être
évidemment déclinée et approfondie
sectoriellement si je puis dire vous
recevrez évidemment mon mon collègue
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse Gabriel Atal c'est vrai aussi
dans le champ de la santé agès firmain
le Baudeau a mené un travail important a
missionné des personnalités qualifié
pour travailler à ces questions dans le
champ de l'hôpital dans le champ de de
de la santé c'est vrai au fond dans
toutes les administrations et au fond
j'élargirai même à tous les opérateurs
avec des agents qui sont pas forcément
des agents fonctionnaires titulaires ou
contractuel mais qui sont délégataires
de service public et ces derniers mois
c'était avant l'été j'ai j'ai réuni pour
la première fois un comité installé un
Comité pour la protection des agents
publics en réunissant à la fois des
administrations mais aussi des
opérateurs je pense à Pôle emploi je
pense à la CAF je pense à la CNAM je
pense à la cave je pense à la poste pour
essayer de voir comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait mutualiser au fond les
initiatives les approches et on se rend
compte d'ailleurs que ces réseaux là ne
se parlent pas suffisamment de tout ce
qui pourrait mettre en commun il y a des
initiatives qui sont très intéressantes
la CNAF a par exemple déployé un outil
de recensement en ligne qui permet à
chaque agent de signaler une agression
immédiatement la Poste a diffusé un
guide sur le dépôt de plainte pour
accompagner les agents dans cette
démarche bref je pense qu'on a un enjeu
de partage d'expérience et de
mutualisation qui qui est très
important je je je crois que les les
drames des derniers mois doivent nous
amener à lutter d'autant plus de vigueur
contre les les agressions que tout ceci
joue aussi sur le rapport avec les
usager et et et créer un sentiment
d'agressivité parfois qui n'est pas bon
pour le service public à la fin et on
doit avoir un regard le plus lucide
possible je dis ça en essayant de
qualifier les faites d'abord avec
humilité m'avez invité à dire toute la
vérité la réalité c'est que on mesure
mal aujourd'hui ces phénomènes là on les
mesure de façon parcellaire j'ai
quelques chiffres à indiquer qui sont
déjà parlants 35000 agressions de
professionnel de santé remonté en 2021
35000 12000 actes d'incivilité remontés
par les caisses d'allocation familiale
en 2022 pour vous donner quelques
exemples mais nous avons aujourd'hui une
difficulté j'y reviendrai à bien mesurer
et on peut être d'ors et déjà certain
qu'il a une forme de allo autour de ces
chiffres là sur les remontées qui sont
effectives et effectué ce qui est
certain quand on réunit les réseaux les
administrations tout le monde fait le
même constat il y a à la fois un enjeu
sur le nombre d'agression mais il y a
aussi un enjeu sur l'intensité des
agressions que vivent les agents
d'ailleurs j'ai décidé de bannir le mot
incivilité de mon vocabulaire quand je
parlais de ces sujets là je me suis
rendu compte à quel point il était
parfois contreproductif ce n'est pas des
incivilités que vivent les agents
publics ce sont des menaces et des
agressions la réalité c'est qu'il y a
quelques années on pouvait se dire que
on commençait par un dialogue un peu
hérité puis ça se terminait par des
menaces
aujourd'hui tous les réseaux nous
remontent le fait que on démarre plutôt
par des menaces et parfois on va au pire
à des agressions à des cûpts ou parfois
au drames que j'ai évoqué en en
introduisant et au fond ça montre qu'il
y a des causes exogènes et que les
services publics voient un certain
nombre de dérives de notre société
derrière les cas dramatiques que j'ai
mentionné sont parfois des sujets de
santé mentale la professeur à Saint-Jean
de lu c'était pas un cas de
radicalisation c'était un enjeu de santé
mentale parfois c'est le fait du
terrorisme de l'islamisme qui a touché
nos agents publics toutes les dérives de
notre société qui déferent et puis il
faut aussi avoir la lucidité de
constater qu'il y a parfois des causes
endogènes je le dis parce que c'est ce
que nous remontent nos administrations
parfois des agents placés dans des
situations de devoir appliquer des
démarches administratif trop complexe
pas assez lisible d'être mis dans des
mauvaises conditions ben tout ça crée
aussi
un sentiment d'irritation qui peut
ensuite arriver à l'agressivité c'est le
téléphone qui est pas décroché c'est des
temps d'attendre très long et quand on
on on discute notamment dans le secteur
hospitalier les agents publics nous le
disent parfois des agents des des des
patients qui ont attendu pendant 9h aux
urgences bah oui ils sont dans des
situations où l'agressivité vient plus
vite et donc ça montre à quel point il
faut prendre ce sujet avec humilité mais
aussi se travailler sur toutes les
causes y compris les causes racines de
nos notre propre complexité
administrative si on veut essayer de de
de pouvoir progresser alors j'ai
présenté en septembre un plan euh de
protection des agents publics avec un
fil rouge qui est de ne jamais laisser
les agents seuls je crois que cette
idée-là euh c'est une idée qui peut être
un fil conducteur à l'ensemble de notre
action jamais seul pour pouvoir mieux
mesuré il faut je le disais avoir plus
d'homogénéité c'est le premier axe de
priorité du plan mieux mesurer les
violences et les menaces jamais seul
aussi quand il s'agit des
administrations pour mutualiser dans une
logique de prévention il s'agira et je
le décrirai de formation de déploiement
de matériel d'accompagnement humain
jamais seul aussi pour pouvoir mieux
protéger c'est le troisème axe de
priorité que j'ai voulu porter dès lors
que des faits sont avérés que ce soit
des menaces ou ou des agressions je je
détaille peut-être très rapidement
avantir ouvrir no échanges en détaillant
le premier axe sur la nécessité de mieux
qualifier les situations la réalité je
le disais j'y reviens pas c'est que
toutes les administrations ne mesurent
pas aujourd'hui et puis quand on mesure
on n pas de langage commun pour pouvoir
qualifier et quantifier les agressions
tout le monde n'a pas le même les mêmes
curseurs si je puis dire et donc on a un
travail am mener là-dessus et puis il
faut être en capacité aussi de
mesurer de façon continue pour pouvoir
réagir et anticiper se dire là il y a un
point de service public il y a un
guichet où on a un certain nombre de
signaux faibles qui doivent nous
conduire à mettre des actions de
prévention à renforcer la sécurité et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
annoncé qu'on allait travailler en deux
temps le premier temps c'est de pouvoir
mettre en place un baromètre commun à
l'ensemble des administrations pour
mesurer précisément le nombre et la
nature des actes de violence subis par
les agents publics et pouvoir suivre
leur évolution on va s'appuyer pour se
faire sur un dispositif qui est mis en
place par les services statistiques du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui est déployé
auprès de 25000 agents publics donc sur
une base large qui nous permettra
d'avoir une granularité fine dans
beaucoup et dans la majorité des
administrations et donc on pourra
publier une première édition de ce
baromètre au prier semestre 2024 pour
pouvoir avoir un suivi annuel et
régulier de ces actes de violence et
d'agression mais je le dis il faut aller
plus loin il faut aussi qu'on puisse
mettre en place des instruments dans
chaque administration pour pouvoir de
façon continue mesurer et remonter c'est
une des mission première que j'ai fixé à
notre comité de protection des agents
publics qui réunit donc l'ensemble des
administrations et l'ensemble des
opérateurs de travailler à la
construction de cet outil commun qui
sera complémentaire du baromètre annuel
deuxème axe je le disais c'est mieux
prévenir mettre en commun les outils de
prévention formation matériel rel moyen
financier moyens humain la formation est
essentielle elle peut pas être la seule
réponse évidemment mais on se rend
compte que pouvoir accompagner les
agents dans des actions de prévention et
de formation ça fait beaucoup sur la
capacité à gérer l'agressivité à
organiser aussi parfois les services
pour pouvoir mieux prévenir les actes et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle ces
derniers mois on a travaillé essayer de
mutualiser l'ensemble des offres de
formation qui existaient y compris chez
les opérateurs certains étaient très
avancés sur ces questionslà travailler
avec des prestataires externes je pense
à la poste notamment qui a fait beaucoup
de travail pour ses postiers sur cette
questionl et donc j'ai demandé à la
direction interministériale de la
transformation publique la dititp de
faire ce travail de mutualisation des
offres de formation ce qu'elle a fait
euh
le dispositif de formation est désormais
prêt il sera à la fois présentiel et
distantiel et nous le testons au au près
d'agents public ces dernières semaines
nous
l'avons déployé à Marseille sur une
première formation près de 40 agents
publics d'administrations diverses
certains agents notamment de de France
service mais aussi d'autres
administrations et on envoie toute
l'utilité on va aussi le tester en sc
saint d'ici les prochains jours et on
mettra à disposition la version
distantielle sur notre outil de de
déploiement des formations qui s'appelle
mentor pour la fonction publique pour
avoir le dispos complet présentiel et
distantiel c'est un module qui est très
complet je vous en cite quelques
chapitres connaître ses droits et ses
devoirs organiser la prévention
intervenir et soutenir les agents
signaler parler écouter prendre en
charge et prévenir la récidive un
certain nombre d'approches qui sont
extrêmement concrètes on travaille
évidemment avec le CNFPT pour la
territoriale et la NFH pour la fonction
publique hospitalière pour pouvoir
déployer C ces outils là
formation matériel et dispositif de
protection on doit pouvoir accélérer
dans le déploiement de caméras de vidéo
protection de boutons d'alerte on voit
qu'il y a des boutons d'alerte qui sont
assez efficaces vous savez c'est ces
boutons où quand on appuie une fois
c'est d'abord les proches du service
deux fois on remonte à la hierérarchie
trois fois ça sonne directement à la
gendarmerie ou à la police on a
travaillé avec l'UGAP donc la plateforme
d'achat de la fonction publique pour
avoir des marchés qui sont prêtes à
l'emploi et j'ai souhaité mettre des
fonds financiers pour pouvoir accélérer
le déploiement de ces dispositifs de
protection et de pas avoir de blocage à
court terme j'ai annoncé c'était cet été
dans un premier temps qu'on allit
débloquer 1 million d'euros j'ai
augmenté ses fonds à 3 millions d'euros
je l'ai annoncé cette semaine puisque
j'ai réuni l'ensemble des organisations
syndical et l'ensemble des employeurs
publics pour travailler en commun sur
ces questionsl et donc j'ai pu leur
indiquer qu'on débloquer ce fond de 3
millions d'euros pour accélérer le
déploiement de ces matériaux de
protection dans l'ensemble des des
administrations et puis j'ai évoqué sur
cette notion de mutualisation les moyens
humains qu'on doit pouvoir mettre à
disposition d'administration on voit
parfois de façon pas assez formalisée
mais ou systématisée plutôt le travail
très utile que peuvent faire nos
référents dans les commissariats et les
gendarmeries pour accompagner des
administrations c'est déjà le cas dans
des CHU par exemple pour pouvoir
travailler sur le bâtimentaire sur
l'organisation du service comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour avoir moins d'agents
seul quand ils sont dans des situations
de devoir aller travailler par exemple
en extérieur de façon nomade la DG FIP
notamment a mené un travail intéressant
sur ces questionslà et donc nous sommes
en train de travailler à une convention
entre le Ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère de la transformation et de la
fonction publique pour pouvoir
systématiser la mise à disposition des
référents dans les poli des
commissariats et les gendarmeries pour
que il puisse être à disposition des
administrations qu'ell souhaitaent pour
les accompagner 3è axe d'accompagnement
c'est de pouvoir mieux protéger les les
agents je le disais on a amélioré nos
dispositifs peut-être qu'on aura ces
échanges là ces dernières années sur la
la protection fonctionnelle notamment
vous l'évoquez monsieur le Président il
y avait encore pour moi des angles morts
dans ces dispositifs là je vais en
évoquer deux le premier c'est la
capacité des agents à aller au bout des
dépôts de plainte on voit bien que bien
souvent les les les agents subissent le
fait de devoir déposer plainte comme une
forme de double peine ils vivent une
agression sur leur lieu de travail et
ensuite on leur dit mais vous allez
déposer plainte demain sur votre temps
de repos c'est pas des soignants nous
font la la la réponse directement mais
ça devrait pas marcher comme ça parfois
ils le vivent comme une exposition
supplémentaire en disant est-ce que je
vais pas me remettre une deuxième fois
en première ligne en devant porter
moi-même la plainte je pense qu'il y a
deux enjeux par rapport à cette
problématique là qui est essentielle la
première c'est déjà de pouvoir déployer
le bon accès au droit et les bonnes
pratiques il est déjà possible par
exemple pour un agent qui déposerait
plainte d'inscrire comme adresse
l'adresse de son administration et pas
l'adresse de son domicile ça c'est des
bonnes pratiques qui sont déjà
existantes et qu'on doit pouvoir
déployer c'est des choses qui sont aussi
concrètes que ça et puis il y avait
quand même un blocage qui était un
blocage au niveau de la loi c'est que
aujourd'hui une administration sauf dans
des cas qui sont aujourd'hui très
restreints n'a pas la possibilité de
porter plainte en lieu et place de
l'agent qui est agressé donc je souhaite
qu'on puisse corriger ce dispositif
législatif on a travailler avec la
Chancellerie à un article de loi je le
soumettrai à la concertation dans le
cadre de la préparation et des
concertations sur un projet de loi pour
la fonction publique que je souhaite
porter et cet article là qui donne la
possibilité aux agents publics ou au
délégataires de service public je crois
qu'on doit le porter de façon assez
élargie de porter plainte à la place des
agents euh ça sera à mon avis un signal
aussi essentiel qu'on enverra dans nos
administrations 2ème dispositif que je
veux parfaire que j'ai pu évoquer c'est
l'amélioration euh ou l'extension de la
protection fonctionnelle à titre
conservatoire vous l'avez adopté dans le
précédent quinena de pouvoir étendre la
protection fonctionnelle à titre
conservatoire aux ayant droits euh
aujourd'hui on a une protection
fonctionnelle pour les aendroits vous
avez adopté et amélioré le dispositif
avec une protection fonctionnelle
conservate mais elle ne concerne pas les
aant droits or les menaces portent
parfois sur la famille des agents
publics et donc la capacité de
mobilisation immédiate de la protection
fonctionnelle elle doit aussi pouvoir
s'appliquer derrière je le dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité il y a le droit et
puis il y a l'accès au
droit on doit pouvoir améliorer et ça
c'est un travail qui est là aussi dans
l'mission de ce ce comité de protection
que j'ai mis en place un travail qui
doit être mené ministère par ministère
et je dirais versant par versant pour
parfaire notre dispositifs d'accès à la
protection fonctionnelle on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui dans la pratique euh et
et d'ailleurs je je je le dis peut-être
par anticipation j'ai peu de statistique
j'ai pas de statistiqu aujourd'hui à
vous donner sur le nombre de protections
fonctionnelles demandé euh sur euh les
les les les protections fonctionnelles
qui sont accordé donc j'ai demandé qu'on
mène de manière extrêmement rapide un
travail de recensement dans tous les
ministères euh Gabriel Attal mène cette
démarche là pour l'éducation nationale
mais on on doit la mener pour tous les
ministères euh sur l'effectivité du
droit et je crois que c'est c'est
souvent ça ceux qui croent voilà les les
premiers axes je je le dis humblement
qu'on a mis en place ça nécessite un
travail qui doit être poursuivi dans le
temps ça peut pas être des annonces qui
ne sont pas suivies de ce travail
approfondi ça doit mobiliser absolument
tous les acteurs je pense aux
organisations syndicales je pense aux
employeurs et et et évidemment le
travail que vous
menez le travail parlementaire qui est
mené je crois est vraiment essentiel
pour pouvoir enrichir l'approche et et
approfondir ses différents axes de
travail monsieur le ministre merci pour
la
la présente bien le cadre de de votre
action et évidemment ce que vous nous
avez décrit concerne les trois fonctions
publiques on va essayer de cerner plus
spécifiquement euh la problématique
posée par enfin les les les les
personnes qui travaillent à l'éducation
nationale dans la diversité de de leur
fonctions euh
moi d'abord dans une première question
je voudrais savoir quel quels sont les
comment vous travaillez avec l'Éducation
nationale justement pour appréender ces
spécificités des métiers de l'éducation
nationale tout à l'heure vous vous vous
avez au début de votre propos essayer
enfin dit que l'objectif était d'essayer
qu'un qu'un fonctionnaire soit jamais
seul ce qu'on peut très bien comprendre
euh dans de nombreuses métiers de la
fonction publique mais un enseignant par
définition il est seul dans sa classe
donc comment vous arrivez à intégrer euh
ces
spécificités quel est le le le l'espace
de dialogue ou le les modalités de
travail avec l'Éducation nationale
là-dessus c'est c'est ma première
question euh je je notamment euh est-ce
qu'il y a des mesures spécifiques qui
sont envisagées quand vous parlez des
personnels de guichet alors on voit bien
à quel type de fonction ça peut faire
référence en gros c'est tous ceux qui
sont euh tous les agents qui sont en
comp contact avec le public est-ce que
le personneléducation nationale qui par
définition aussi est en contact avec le
public il est assimilé à cette à ce que
les agents de guichet ENF les mesures
que vous envisagez de prendre sont sont
aussi transposables pour les agents pour
les personnel d'éducation
nationale sur le deuxème question sur la
protection fonctionnelle je pense que
mes collègues y reviendront je n'en
doute pas j'ai j'ai moi une question
parce qu'on en a beaucoup entendu parler
depuis le début de de ces
auditions euh il y a une il y a une
question sur à la fois sur les délais
comment peut-on accélérer les choses et
jusqu'où étendre cette protection
fonctionnelle je pense notamment aux
contractuels qui à ma connaissance ne
sont pas concernés par la protection
fonctionnelle al on sait que dans
l'éducation nationale il y a recours
même si ça reste en en en
desortions relativement faibles mais
quand même croissante à des contractuels
ce qui est envisagé de la part du
gouvernement d'étendre le dispositif de
la protection fonctionnelle au cont
actuel je vais on prend toutes les
séries de questions si vous voulez bien
ça sera peut-être plus simple euh
Marie-Pierre Monier merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre alors
tout d'abord dans la loi
2021- 119 du 24 août 2021 confortant le
respect des principes de la République
il y avait deux articles qui avaient été
introduits un qui intrdisit le un délit
qui punit de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et
75000 € d'amende le fait d'user de menac
de violence à l'gard de toute personne
participant à l'exécution d'une mission
de service public et dans l'article 36
c'était un délit qui était puni de 3 ans
d'emprisonnement et 45000 € d'amende sur
le fait de révéler des informations
relatives à une personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publicque ou chargé de
mission service public donc ces deux
articles sont à disposition est-ce que
vous avez des informations à votre
connaissance est-ce qu'ils ont été à ce
jour ils ont donné déjà lieu à des
condamnations parce que ce sont des
outils qui existent c'est vrai que moi
je suis à la commission cult donc je
vais peut-être passer sur l'éducation
éducation nationale paraît plus que
jamais aujourd'hui en prise avec les
vifs débats éclivages que qui traverse
notre société sur la laïcité en témoigne
la recrudescence des des atteintes au
principes de laïcité et la forte
autocensure de la profession enseignante
cette lame de fond est-elle également
visible dans la fonction publique dans
son ensemble l'attentat qui a conduit à
la mort de Dominique Bernard a enclenché
une nouvelle réflexion sur la
sécurisation des établissements
scolaires vis-à-vis des intrusions
extérieures l'éducation nationale
pourrait-elle s'inspirer peut-être de
bonnes pratiques qui sont à votre
connaissance et déjà à l'œuvre dans
d'autres lieux publics nous avons avec
mes collègues Max Brisson et anque
billon fait un rapport bilan des mesures
éducativ du
quinquena et nous avons mis en lumière
le sentiment des enseignants de ne pas
être assez soutenus par l'institution en
cas de remise en cause de leur autorité
ainsi que d'une moindre prise en cause
de leurs plainte par la police et la
justice comparativement à d'autres
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique ou chargé d'une maision de
service civique nous appelions notamment
dans nos recommandations à
l'automaticité de la protection
fonctionnelle pour les enseignants et à
la garantie de la même célérité dans le
suivi des dépôt de plainte des
enseignants que pour d'autres personnes
âgées de mission service public est-ce
que vous avez des éléments de
comparaison parce que le président
Lafond l'a bien expliqué c'est pas la
même situation dans l'enseignement que
dans la fonction publique mais est-ce
que vous avez des éléments de
comparaison sur l'exposition des
enseignants des agressions et menaces
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des agents de la
fonction publique est-ce que vous avez
des données sur l'accompagnement par
leur institution suite à des agressions
menaces subies par des agents ainsi que
le suivi des plaintes pour l'ensemble là
de la fonction publique et
comparativement pour l'éducation
nationale où on s' situe et puis le
président a parlé aussi de euh la
protection fonctionnel qui nous
interroge voilà est-ce que vous c'est
pareil là euh combien est-ce qu'il y a
d'agents qui qui ont qui la demande par
an est-ce qu'il y a quel est le
pourcentage de refus quel est de moyenne
réponse et quels sont les principaux
motif de reçu de refus pardon de la
protection
fonctionnelle merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre merci pour vos propos vous
avez exposé un certain nombre d'éléments
un certain nombre également de pistes
pour avancer sur ces dossiers notamment
sur les symptômes vous avez parlé
dispositif de protection fonctionnelle
vous avez parlé bouton d'urgence dépôt
de plainte c'est évidemment tout à fait
nécessaire mais moi je voulais revenir
davantage sur la question des causes
vous avez euh justement préciser dans
votre propos liminaire qu'il n'y avait
pas que la question de la radicalisation
dont évidemment les événements actuelles
se sont fait dramatiquement l'écho mais
aussi les questions de santé mentale qui
sont à prendre en compte
je voulais savoir si vous aviez des
éléments chiffrés
d'évolution de ces problèmes de santé
mentale notamment vis-à-vis des
agressions des personnels de l'Éducation
nationale puisqu'on a beaucoup
entendu après la crise du covid-19 que
nos jeunes collégiens lycéens étudiants
avaient été particulièrement impactés
fragilisés psychologiquement et
mentalement donc voilà je voulais savoir
s'il y avait des des des mesures
d'évolution de ces problèmes de santé
mental qui pourrai être à l'origine des
agressions et puis savoir si vous aviez
des pistes aussi pour y répondre
puisqu'on sait en parallèle qu'on manque
de manière patente de place dans nos
services de psychiatrie dans nos
hôpitaux merci Madame Garnier madame
monsieur piernoir pardon puis madameage
brigot merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour pour vos
propos pour votre présence
aujourd'hui on distingue en effet les
les les deux secteurs enfin on est là
sur une mission qui s'attache plutôt à
regarder les les faits sur dans le
domaine de l'éducation national
néanmoins vous avez parlé de la fonction
des fonctions publiques dans dans leur
ensemble et vous avez parlé beaucoup de
de de chiffres de de statistiques de
baromètres h sur les incivilités terme
que vous bannissez en tout cas sur les
menaces euh et sur les causes est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire quelques mot
sur sur l'origine euh sur peut-être
l'éloignement euh réel ou supposé de des
services publics auprès de la population
est-ce que c'est le motif numéro 1 des
des incivilités ou des menaces qui sont
constater et plus globalement vous
l'avez dit aussi sont les dérives de
notre société son sont vos termes à quoi
vous pensez exactement quel quel type de
dérives euh et et là j'en viens au au
contexte d'éducation
nationale vous vous vous évoquez des la
formation très bien vous évoquz du
matériel euh en tant qu'ancien
enseignant mais comme beaucoup je je ne
peux pas me résigné à à recommander à
mes anciens collègues d'enseigner avec
une vitre de protection voir avec un
bout avec un bouton d'alerte en cas de
en cas de menace physique l'enseignant
président Lafond l'a rappelé et par
nature la plupart du temps 90 % de son
temps seul devant des des élèves parfois
aussi seul devant des parents
d'élèves comment comment prendre ça à
bras le cor en tout cas je je ne peux
pas M résoudre et et sur le dépôt de
plainte vous avez dit que peut-être
l'administration dans son ensemble
pouvait se pouvait elle-même déposer
plainte en lieu et place de l'enseignant
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
envisagé pour l'enseignant quand je dis
que l'enseignant est seul il est aussi
parfois dramatiquement seul au sein de
son établissement scolaire est-ce qu'on
peut garantir qu' d'avoir un soutien
queles que soient les conditions et avec
une parfois une un droit de retrait qui
soit un petit peu plus automatique que
ce qu' l'a été constaté dans les faits
dramatiques que nous avons tous en tête
merci Monsieur Madame Brig puis Monsieur
Pierre zoulias merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le ministre
pour toutes les informations que vous
avez donné effectivement comme vient de
le rappeler mon collègue vous AAZ dit
l'essentiel au début en disant que
c'était le dérive de notre la dérive de
notre société tristement j'ai envie de
dire et peut-être même à pleurer parce
que ce métier d'enseignant qui est l'un
des plus beaux à mon sens puisque je
l'ai été pour ça que je le dis
aujourd'hui ne fait plus rêver et c'est
quand même bien triste il ne fait plus
rêver ce métier et il ne fait plus rêver
parce que on peut plus aujourd'hui être
enseignant de manière apaisée
pratiquement partout donc c'est un vrai
sujet quand même parce que c'est
l'avenir de nos enfants Les enfants de
ce pays qui est en jeu donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment au-delà de tout ce
que vous avez expliqué dans
l'administration mais y compris au
niveau de l'éducation nationale de
mettre en place des choses très
techniques je pense qu'il y a un
problème de fond à régler si on veut
arriver à bouger les lignes alors vous
avez dit que à la rentrée enfin en 2024
vous allez mettre en place un baromètre
euh pour essayer d'analyser tous les
faets d'agression dans la fonction
publique de manière globale est-ce que
vous avez aussi l'intention d'en faire
une cartographie parce que je pense que
ça aussi c'est intéressant une une
cartographie me semble un élément
essentiel parce qu'il y a probablement
dans notre pays des endroits plus
violents que d'autres des endroits où
les faits sont plus violents que
d'autres des endroits où les gens sont
plus menacés que d'autres et c'est
intéressant de le poser et de le dire
parce que c'est en en posant la réalité
de ce qui se passe dans nos territoires
qu'on peut trouver des solutions qui
sont peut-être pas les les mêmes dans le
Nord dans le sud dans l'Est dans l'Ouest
et je pense que ça ça semble il me
semble je ne sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais que ça me paraît essentiel
d'avoir une véritable cartographie
chiffrée de toutes cess dans la fonction
publique d'une manière
générale pierre
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur le le ministre je voudrais
revenir sur la protection fonctionnelle
aujourd'hui la la pratique notamment
dans dans le domaine de l'éducation
nationale fait que c'est l'agent qui
demande la protection fonctionnelle à
son supérieur hiérarchique qui a le
pouvoir discrétionnaire de lui accorder
ou de ne pas lui accorder et qui juge si
la responsabilité propre et individuelle
de l'agent est engagé ou si c'est une
une protection qui doit être accordé en
fonction de son travail voil est-ce
qu'on peut pas imaginer un système où on
renverserait la charge de la preuve
c'est-à-dire que la la protection
fonctionnelle sera accordée de droit au
fonctionnairees qui la demande et
ensuite ça serait son supérieur
hiérarchique qui en fonction des des
conditions lui retirit ou pas j'y vois
un gros avantage c'est d'abord renforcer
le soutien aux fonctionnaires leur
indiquer que l'État est derrière eux et
les protégera je trouve ça fondamental
et par ailleurs ça permet le recours
puisque si la protection fonctionnelle
est de droit et que le supérieur
hérarchique ne l'accorde pas il y a la
possibilité d'un recours des
fonctionnaires qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui quand un supérieur
hiérarchique refuse la protection
fonctionnelle les choses s'arrêtent
voilà
alors vous vous savez parce que moi j'ai
essayé plusieurs fois de de proposer des
amendement que les les parlementaires ne
peuvent pas le faire parce qu'on est
bloqué par l'article 40 donc est-ce que
dans les les les révisions législatives
que vous envisagez est-ce qu'on pourrait
discuter de quelque chose qui pourrait
ressembler à ça je finis mon propos en
disant que il y a des des très grandes
disparités entre les les mondes des
fonctionnaires chez les policiers la
fonctionnaire la la protection
fonctionnelle est quasiment d'office
elle est jamais discutée chez les
enseignants vous le savez les choses
sont beaucoup plus compliquées merci
monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais commencer par un prop
propos général pour resserrer ensuite
vous avez évoqué les différentes
fonctions publiques et les violences
dans les différentes fonctions
publiques je dois vous dire que la
complexification née d'Internet dans les
relations entre les usagers et la
fonction publique contribue je dis bien
contribue elle n'excuse pas mais elle
contribue parfois à des violences et à
détention quand vous avez des personnes
qui butent sur internet alors qu'elles
veulent liquider leur retraite entrer en
contact avec la
carsate c'est le parcours du combattant
ça relève parfois de Kanta je prends que
cet exemple là je pourrais en citer
beaucoup d'autres comme lorsque vous
avez quelqu'un par exemple qui est
demandeur d'emploi qui reçoit une
convocation qui est datée du 16 novembre
pour le 17 novembre et donc le 17
novembre au mieux il reçoit le courrier
lorsque la Poste fonctionne bien et
lorsque la Poste ne fonctionne pas bien
le courrier peut arriver le 18 et
entre-temps le temps d'écrire un
courrier ou d'envoyer un mail pour dire
j'ai reçu le courrier en retard il est
radié donc je dis bien je n'excuse pas
mais cela explique les tensions et
parfois ce sont des gens des Français
moyens comme vous et moi qui se
retrouvent dans une situation
particulièrement difficile et qui
peuvent péter les plombs donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je souhaite é
vraiment insisteré sur ce point-là et
dire il faut tenter toujours d'humaniser
le service public qu' puisse y avoir un
recours et qu'on n'est pas uniquement
des lignes téléphoniques des messages
pré-enregistrés et des sites internet
sur lesquels butent un certain nombre de
nos concitoyen je vais en venir à la
violence qui s'exprime dans le monde
éducatif je il y a plusieurs types de
violence qui euh qui se manifeste et en
fonction des niveaux scolaires ce que
j'ai pu observer c'est que les violences
sont de nature complètement différentes
lorsqu'il s'agit des écoles primaires
maternelles élémentaires ce sont souvent
sur un fond de contentieux parental de
divorce de garde de garde alterné de
procès en cours et finalement les
enseignants les maîtresses et les
maîtres les directeurs d'école se
retrouvent finalement à mi-chemin de
voir réguler ce que la justice n'a pas
encore régulé et ce que les partis n'ont
pas accepté
donc ça c'est la première type de
premier c'est le premier type de de
violence qui me remonte que j'observe et
que je lis à travers la presse ou que
des directeurs d'école que des syndicats
me font remonter parfois même des
parents d'élèves deuxième type de
violence à laquelle j'assiste et que je
vois et qui remonte beaucoup cette
fois-ci c'est le niveau collège et lycée
lorsqu'on est dans les collèges et les
lycées les premiers agents qui sont au
contact de la population ce ne sont pas
les agents de l'éducation nationale ce
sont les agents des collectivit
ce sont les agents du Département ce
sont les agents de la région je suis
conseiller régional lorsque je me rends
dans les établissements dans les lycées
pour participer à un conseil
d'administration celles et ceux qui sont
à l'entrée à qui il faut montrer patte
blanche ce sont les agents de la région
très exceptionnellement vous pouvez
avoir un proviseur ou un principal qui
est debout et qui accueille les élèves
ça c'est une image d'entend qui
aujourd'hui on qu'on ne voit plus tout
simplement parce qu'il y a une surcharge
de travail une complexification des
missions de chef d'établissement et les
principaux comme les proviseurs sont
davantage dans leur dans leur bureau à
accueillir des parents à accueillir des
équipes pédagogiques et beaucoup moins
sur le pas de la porte pour accueillir
les élèves mais souvent ce sont donc les
élèves qui arrivent et qui sont une
proie pour un certain nombre de
personnes malintentionnées des dealers
mais des gens qui viennent raquetter ou
qui viennent
chaparder et finalement celles et ceux
qui s'interposent qui sortent de leur
poste d'obser tion pour s'interposer
parfois ce sont les agents des
départements ou les agents des régions
et enfin il y a de mon point de vue ce
qu'on a
pu tous et toutes déplorer ce sont la
radicalisation et les conséquences de la
radicalisation lorsqu'elle fait
irruption à l'intérieur des
établissements scolaires à travers des
parents qui sont mécontents courossés
d'un programme scolaire d'une sortie
pédagogique ou parfois ce sont des
parents qui ne sont pas du tout
radicalisés mais qui et qui il viennent
contester une sanction qui a été
infligée à leurs frères ou à leurs sœurs
ou à leur fils ou à leurs fillees ceuxà
ils viennent il montrent pas de blanche
ce sont les parents c'est une famille
qui est convoquée parfois ou c'est une
famille qui a obtenu rendez-vous qui
rentre de manière complètement licé dans
l'établissement scolaire et qui commet
les violences à l'intérieur tout cela
pour vous dire Monsieur le Ministre que
je formule deux vœux le premier vœux
c'est que vous puissiez associer les
collectivités territoriales département
région et municipalité à la réflexion
qui est la vôtre pour ne pas que que des
mesures que vous pourriez mettre en
œuvre demain ne bénéficient uniquement
aux agents de l'éducation nationale mais
qu'elle puisse aussi bénéficier aux
agents des collectivités territoriales
le deuxième vœux que je formule c'est
celui de faciliter le dépôt de plainte
par l'administration parce
qu'effectivement on se rend compte que
lorsque ce sont des violences commis
autour d'une école finalement souvent la
directrice d'école le directeur d'école
appelle la municipalité et par les
relations privilégiées qui existent
entre le maire ou l'adjoint au maire ou
l'adjointe au maire à la sécurité le
rendez-vous est pris facilement pour
aller déposer plainte lorsqu'on passe au
collège au lycée finalement il y a une
distance qui s'installe et c'est
beaucoup plus difficile on dit au prof
ben prenez rendez-vous on dit à l'agent
de la collectivité départementale ou
régionale prenez rendez-vous
effectivement prendre rendez-vous c'est
aussi un parcours du combattant et c'est
un c-etê pour l'établissement qui doit
remplacer celui ou celle qui a abandonné
son poste pour des raisons complètement
valables pour aller déposer plaintte
mais quand quelqu'un va déposer plainte
qu'il fait la queue pendant tro ou 4 ben
le poste il est
vacant ENF dernier intervenant à la
marque merci messieur les présidents
monsieur le ministre je ne vais pas bien
qu'ancien enseignant évoquer les
violences éducatives mais nous sommes
pour beaucoup d'entre nous sénateurs de
départements ruraux et dans les
départements ruraux il y a des toutes
petites communes où il y a un agent que
l'on appelle secrétaire de mairie il y
avait peu nous travaillons nous avons
travaillé sur le statut des secrétaires
de mairie qui elles aussi font parfois
l'objet
euh peut-être pas de violence physique
mais souvent d'incivilité et moi
j'aimerais savoir tout simplement par
quel Canau celles-ci vont vous remonter
parce qu'elles ne font pas forcément
l'objet de plainte
euh est-ce que cela va être le cas dans
le dans l'installation de votre
baromètre en
2024 quels outils allez-vous utiliser
pour que ces ces informationsl vous
remonte de façon à ce que nous puissions
les uns et les autres avoir la réception
de d'un publque de façon pacifiée ce qui
n'est pas toujours le camp j'ai entend
toujours le cas j'ai entendu parler tout
à l'heure de de de violence
psychiatrique ou des gens qui qui
étaient un petit peu instabl et qui
venaient parfois effectivement perturber
perturber nos agents nous avons vraiment
besoin d'eux il se retrouvent souvent
seul confronté le maire n'est pas là ils
ont pas forcément envie de porter
plainte parce que d'abord on sait qui
c'est euh qui est l'auteur de ces
infractions ils sont seuls à la mairie
et pour le coup il peut peuvent pas
anonymiser leur leurs
plainte voilà si personne d'autre ne
souhaite poser de questions on va
laisser le ministre
répondre merci monsieur le Président
alors je je
répondrai sans
préter micro s coupé je je je répondrai
sans sans préempter l'audition que vous
aurez avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale je crois qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'éléments
qui devront être abordés avec le
Ministre en charge et pardon parce que
je mon objectif est pas de frustrer
essayer mais je préfère pas répondre à
côté ou donner essayer d'inventer des
informations que je n'ai pas je vais
essayer de de le faire le plus
précisément possible au fond moi mon
travail il est très transversal de poser
un cadre poser parfois une doctrine
d'essayer de mutualiser les outils et
ensuite je l'ai dit dans mon propos
liminaire d'avoir un travail approfondi
en interaction et c'était votre question
monsieur le Président avec mes collègues
dans le cadre du comité que nous avons
mis en place de protection des agents
publics nous sommes évidemment vu avec
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
pour aborder ces ces sujetsl nos
cabinets travaillent ensemble justement
à l'approfondissement des mesures voir
comment est-ce qu'on peut justement
articuler les mesures principielles et
transversales et les mesures qui sont et
qui doivent être spécifique à
l'éducation nationale et c'est vraiment
dans ce CADR là qu'on qu'on va aborder
les chose vous vous plus précisément
évoquez la question de de ne pas être
seul vous avez parfaitement raison un
professeur il est dans beaucoup de cas
en tout cas pas toujours mais dans
beaucoup de cas seul devant sa classe et
et parfois même l'organisation
hiérarchique des établissements fait que
les les professeurs peuvent parfois se
se sentir seul mais quand moi j'en
faisais une notion fil rouge et
transversale de l'action je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup d'éléments qu'on peut
appliquer quand même à l'éducation
nationale je disais jamais seul dans la
façon de mesurer mettre en place un
baromètre commun avec les mêmes curseurs
sur ce qu'on appelle une incivilité sur
ce qu'on appelle une menace sur ce qu'on
appelle une
agression tout ça ça peut être utile
aussi pour embarquer l'ensemble des
administrations dont l'éducation
nationale pour avoir des outils de
mesures commun ça commence par là de pas
laisser les les professeurs les
enseignants seul c'est de considérer
qu'ils sont des agents publics avec leur
spécificité mais qu' sont des agents
publics avec tous les droits qui doivent
aller avec et et et toute l'attention
qu'on doit leur porter et donc je pense
que ça commence par des instruments de
mesures commun j'aiévoqué cette notion
de ne pas être seul parce que tous les
dispositifs que j'ai évoqué à la fois de
formation oui je pense que ça peut
évidemment s'appliquer aussi à des
enseignants alors évidemment avec des
des adaptations à à à mener mais j'ai
pour ça nommé devant vous les intitulés
ou les modules des formations qu'on a
travaillé on voit bien par exemple que
la notion de connaissance de ses droits
et ses devoirs bah quand on est un
enseignant ça vaut parfaitement et donc
on peut l'appliquer à l'éducation
nationale la gestion de l'agressivité
face par exemple vous l'évoquez monsieur
sénateur à un professeur agressif ou un
tiers agressif dans un établissement ça
peut être aussi utile de former nos
enseignants à ces situations et c'est
une façon de ne pas les laisser seul
d'une certaine façon même si on va pas
changer l'organisation par nature de la
classe la question du matériel on voit
bien c'est des éléments dont je dispose
pour le coût de l'éducation nationale
sur la sécurisation des établissements
aujourd'hui l'État et les collectivités
ont investi 170 millions d'euros depuis
2017 pour la sécurisation des
établissements 3/4 des collèges et des
lycées sont équipés de système d'alarme
voilà déjà un premier lien pour que
globalement dans l'établissement on
n'est pas un établissement qui soit
isolé certaines collectivités euh sont
allés plus loin euh il y a des euh
dispositifs et des initiatives qui ont
été prises à Marseille pour pouvoir
équiper les professeur de système
d'alerte portatif par exemple euh est-ce
que ça s'applique dans tous les
établissements et j'eneviendrai à votre
question madame la sénatrice sur la
cartographie est-ce que c'est nécessaire
de déployer ça pour tout le monde
partout le ministre de la Fonction
publique ne veut pas apporter la réponse
je crois que le travail doit être mené
avec le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale plus spécifiquement pour se
poser la question de savoir où est-ce
qu'il est utile de déployer par exemple
un système d'alerte général pour
l'établissement ou dans quels
établissements il pourrait être utile de
déployer des équipements portatifs pour
chacun des professeurs est-ce que c'est
utile aujourd'hui partout pour tous les
professeurs du pays je je ne veux pas
aujourd'hui préempter une réponse à une
telle question les dispositifs
de micro micro micro chers collègue
alors sur sur la question du financement
oui le financement de ce type de
dispositif c'est l'état ou ce sont les
collectifs alors c'est porté par les
collectivités qui ont la la charge du
bâtimentaire pour pour les les
établissements et bien souvent il y a
des fonds de l'État
d'accompagnement des collectivités donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai mentionné mais là
aussi je veux pas aller dans un niveau
de granularité dont j'auraai pas les
bonnes réponses j'ai mentionné un
investissement commun en mentionnant les
170 millions de l'État et des
collectivités et donc je peux pas vous
en donner exactement le décompte précis
sur quelle est la part étatique et
quelle est la part collectivité dans ces
170 millions d'euros j'ai évoqué pour
poursuivre les dispositif de protection
là aussi vous l'avez dit vous-même ne
pas laisser un professeur être seul à
devoir porter plainte c'est une façon je
crois de ne pas le laisser seul et et je
vous réponds sans avoir changé
l'organisation de de de la classe
l'accès à la protection fonctionnelle
j'y reviendrai dans quelques instants là
aussi je je crois que si on applique
mieux les dispositifs de protection
fonctionnelle et c'est vraiment un
engagement fort et une direction que le
ministre deéducation nationale souhaite
donner mais là aussi on laisse nos
agents moins seuls donc je crois que
vraiment ce fil rouge là il peut garder
toute sa pertinence y compris pour
l'éducation nationale même si par nature
physiquement si je puux dire
l'organisation des classes fait que
effectivement les les les les
professeurs sont bien souvent seuls dans
les classes vous m'avez interrogé sur la
protection fonctionnelle et et et
l'aspect élargi je n'ai pas de les
éléments pour vous apporter une réponse
sur les suites judiciaires sur notamment
les nouvelles dispositions qui ont été
apportées par la loi de 2021 sur les les
nouvelles dispositions de de protection
fonctionnel mais bien évidemment il y a
un enjeu de bon accès au dispositifs qui
sont existants et j'insiste une seconde
c'est la question au fond que vous
m'avez posé oui parfois je crois en
fonction des ministères ou des versants
de la fonction publique on peut avoir
une application qui est trop
différenciée dans les faites de la
protection fonctionnelle donc je crois
qu'il y a certaines évidences sur le
fait de combler des vides juridiques
j'en ai évoqué deux sur la capacité à
porter plainte où la protection
fonctionn à titre conservatoire pour les
aant droit moi le le débat sur le fait
d'inverser d'une certaine façon la
charge de la preuve mais un débat qui me
semble pas du tout illégitime on pourra
l'avoir d'ailleurs quand on aura une
accroche législative je l'ai évoqué dans
un projet de loi sur la fonction public
autour de la protection fonctionnelle
mais ma conviction la plus profonde pour
vous répondre très sincèrement c'est
d'abord qu'il faut bien appliquer le
droit existant il est pas normal parfois
que on ait des dispositifs qu'on est
créé et qu'on voit que la pratique en
fonction des administrations puisse
différer et donc je pense qu'il y a une
direction très claire à donner et je le
redis c'est vraiment le sens de l'action
en l'occurrence pour l'éducation
nationale du ministre de pouvoir rendre
de façon plus effective de passer les
consignes aux administrations pour
s'organiser pour que la protection
fonctionnelle soit plus largement
accordé et je le dis dans toute la
complexité des choses pour l'éducation
nationale vous aurez à discuter avec le
ministre de ses actions ces actions
notamment contre le harcèlement scolaire
il en a fait une de ses priorités et on
voit bien qu'elle a un juste équilibre
l'actualité la la plus récente sur les
courriers dans les rectorats envoyés
montre que au fond il faut bien être
clair sur le fait que protéger c'est pas
couvrir protéger des agents c'est
respecter le droit c'est le devoir d'une
administration c'est pas à la carte et
ça doit être distinct de faute qui
pourrait être établi par des agents et
je crois qu'il faut garder effectivement
cette approche équilibrée des choses
c'est toute la difficulté je crois de la
mission mais en tout cas pas
d'ambigué sur le fait que dans les
consignes données aux administrations on
on doit rendre l'accès à la procession
fonctionnelle effective à 100 % et je
crois que ça doit être à la fois une
approche transversale et une approche
spécifique à l'éducation
nationale vous
évoquez la question des cause madame la
la la la
sénatrice là non plus j'ai pas
d'éléments chiffrés sur des évolutions
pour qui concerne la santé mentale dans
le champ de l'éducation nationale et et
vraiment vous pourrez interroger mon mon
collègue gabrielal sur cette question là
mais je je reviens quand même sur
effectivement quelques éléments que j'ai
pu énoncer dans dans mon propos
liminaire oui je pense qu'il faut
assumer le fait qu'il a des causes
exogènes et des causes endogènes euh je
crois avir essayer de de le dire avec
clarté il faut bien nommer les choses si
on veut pouvoir ensuite répondre au
problème il y a des causes exogènes j'ai
évoqué le fait que les services publics
subissaient des dérives euh certaines
dérives de notre société les enjeux de
santé mentale sont des enjeux
extrêmement importants particulièrement
postcovid tous les indicateurs le
montrent président de la République a
souhaité qu'il ait un CNR dédié à la
question de la santé mentale et donc je
pense que ça va être un sujet de
mobilisation de société le ministre de
la Santé de la prévention aura
l'occasion de porter ce CNR là c'est
évidemment une dimension très importante
et on voit bien que dans certains cas ce
sont ces sujetsl qui
entraînent des violences sur les agents
j'ai évoqué le cas dramatique d'agès
Lassal j'ai eu l'occasion de de me
rendre avec papendiaille à Saint-Jean de
luuse le jour où elle a été assassiné et
on voit bien que c'était un sujet de de
santé mentale beaucoup plus qu'un sujet
de radicalisation en l'occurrence pour
pour prendre cet exemple mais on a
évidemment aussi des atteintes et des
atteintes notamment en matière de
laïcité sur les services publics qui
peuvent entraîner ensuite des situations
d'agressivité ou de violence et donc on
voit bien que la question de la
radicalisation euh de l'ensuvagement
parfois c'est la l'expression a été
utilisé ou de
décivilisation pour reprendre une
expression que le Président de la
République a assumé elle joue aussi sur
nos services publics il ne sont pas
exents de ça et donc il faut qu'on
puisse les protéger et je veux le dire
sans revenir et vous avez dit à juste
titre on va pas au fond mettre un
plexiglace devant euh euh chaque
enseignant et donc il faut trouver en
fonction de chaque situation ou de
chaque administration une réponse qui
soit adaptée et je crois qu'il faut
faire très attention dans les réponses
qui sont les ntres et dans dans
l'organisation même des services à pas
revenir parfois à des panneaux qu'on
pouvait voir dans certains services
administratif assez agressif pour
l'usager assez menaçant où le premier
signe d'accueil au fond c'est de vous
dire l'amende que vous allez avoir si
vous l'ouvrez un petit peu trop je pense
que les évolutions des sciences
comportementales de ce qu'on a pu faire
évoluer nous montre qu' a peut-être
mieux à faire que de revenir à mettre
des plexiglace partout avec des panneaux
très menaçants pour les usagers et c'est
tout le travail que nous menons avec la
dititp que j'ai mentionné tout à l'heure
pour justement qui au sein de la
Direction interministérielle de la
transformation publique on a des
compétences en sciences comportementales
pour pouvoir dans nos formations dans
l'accompagnement des différentes
administrations travailler avec elles
sur les meilleurs messages à adresser
soit à la fois clairire pour les usagers
et en même temps qui soi pas des
messages qui créent eux-mêmes une
agressivité que subiraient ensuite les
agents public donc pardon pour cette
réponse qui est généraliste mais je
crois pas qu'il a une réponse homogène à
accoller dans toutes les administrations
et singulièrement à l'éducation
nationale et que ça montre tout le
travail qu'on doit mener conjoint
ministère par ministère avec le socle au
fond que que je propose d'apporter à mes
collègues et et au trisersant de de la
fonction de la fonction publique alors
je je reprends vos vos questions alors
certaines étaient au fond très
systémique et très principiell vous
disez VO sur les enseignants la cause
racine sur le le le le métier qui qui
fait plus rêver on pourrait je crois
consacrer une audition entière à la
question et et nous avons eu l'occasion
de de de le faire de l'attractivité de
la fonction public je veux simplement
répondre en deux mots que je pense qu'il
y a des enjeux salariaux si on les évite
on passe je crois à côté d'une partie du
sujet mais en même temps si on ne réduit
la question de l'attractivité qu'au
seuls enjeux salariaux qu'il faut pas
minimiser je pense qu'on passe aussi à
côté du sujet et donc je mentionnerai et
je me contenterai dans le cadre de cette
audition là de mentionner simplement
trois points un la question de
réinvestissement salarial je détaille
pas les les les mesures prises à la fois
pour l'ensemble des agents publics ça
sera 6 milliards d'euros effectif en
année pleine sur les Aug augmentation
des mesures que j'ai pu annoncer avant
l'été et qui sont liées et qui
s'ajoutent aux mesures catégorielles en
l'occurrence pour nos professeurs à
travers les dispositifs de
réinvestissement pour que les
professeurs de notre pays soient mieux
rémunérés ça c'est le premier axe le
deuxième axe à mon sens c'est
l'évolution professionnel il faut donner
plus de perspective d'évolution parfois
ce qui freine l'attractivité c'est des
fonctionnaires qui vous disent moi je
regarde ma collègue qui a 15 ans de plus
que moi qui gagne 150 € de plus par mois
c'est ça qui coince aujourd'hui et donc
le travail qu'on a amené sur les
parcours et les grilles de carrière et à
mon avis un axe important et puis le
troisème axe je me contenterai de cela
pour donner une réponse un peu macro
c'est les conditions de travail j'ai
j'ai j'ai pu mener ces derniers mois et
on vient de la conclure une consultation
auprès des agents de la fonction
publique sur leurs conditions de travail
très concrètees 110000 réponses d'agents
publics jamais on avait eu autant de
fonctionnaires qui avaient répondu à une
telle consultation précisément parce que
on les a interrogé sur des sujets très
concrets qui concernent la santé au
travail qui concerne l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes qui concerne la
simplification au quotidien de leur
tâches qui concerne des enjeux de
management qui concerne des enjeux de
logement pour nos fonctionnaires et la
la la la la réponse et ce qui saute aux
yeux au fond c'est de donner les moyens
à nos fonctionnaires de faire leur
mission parfois dans les dimensions les
plus basiques et je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion de pouvoir en reparler vous
m'interrogez sur le baromètre et
l'opportunité de d'avoir une carte
phographie du
baromètre c'est précisément ce que je
souhaite qu'on puisse faire j'ai évoqué
l'appui qu'on va avoir sur le service
statistique du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est 25000 agents publics donc on va
avoir une photographie qui va être très
fine dans nos services publics et qui
est évidemment sur une cartographie
nationale moi je rendrai absolument
transparente les les chiffres qui vont
remonter de ce paromètre donc ça veut
dire que déjà dans la photographie
annuelle qu'on va avoir on pourra avoir
effectivement une cartographie sur les
différents territoires et les
différentes administrations qui
subissent des agressions ou ou des
menaces mais j'ai aussi indiqué que je
souhaitais qu'on s'arrête pas à cette
photographie annuelle et qu'on ait
administration par administration un
outil de mesure je crois que c'est ça
vise précisément à faire ce que ce que
vous diteson a besoin parfois de repérer
je disais des signaux faibles
c'est-à-dire un guichet un établissement
scolaire ou il y a a eu davantage de
menac c'est ça qui va nous permettre de
réagir et je le dis très clairement on
pourra pas se contenter d'un baromètre
annuel sur la question là on a besoin
les
hôpitaux les hôpitaux ont d'ailleurs
avancé sur cette questionl peut-être
vous aurez l'occasion d'entendre ma ma
collègue firmain lebudeau j'aiévoqué son
travail il y a un observatoire national
des violences c'est ce qui m'a permis
d'ailleurs de vous citer une statistique
sur les 25000 agressions en 2021 sur ces
C ces questionsl et donc on doit
s'appuyer sur les outils existants mais
on doit les élargir pour avoir un outil
de mesure je dirais quotidien ce qui me
permet aussi de répondre à la question
de comment est-ce qu'on embarque la
fonction publique territoriale comment
est-ce qu'on permet à nos secrétaires de
mairie qui sont elles aussi victimes
parfois de menaces ou d'agression de
pouvoir remonter les chiffres donc moi
mon souhait et c'est le travail que j'ai
lancé c'est qu'on puisse avoir cet outil
de mesure commun qu'on puisse proposé à
l'ensemble des administrations la
question m'a été posée aussi par
sénateur Bourgi de comment en quer les
collectivités territoriales dans ce
travail là c'est précisément la raison
pour laquelle j'ai souhaité les réunir
je l'ai fait lundi matin l'ensemble des
employeurs territoriaux l'ensemble des
centres de gestion représentés par la
Fédération nationale des centres de
gestion le CNFPT bref tout ceux qui sont
autour de la table de notre Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique
territoriale justement pour que ces
outil là soit pas pensé pour l'État et
ensuite décliner comme parfois ça peut
arriver pour la fonction publque
territoriale ou pour la fonction public
hospitalière donc précisément le travail
autour des outils de mesure c'est un axe
de travail que j'ai proposé de
travailler de façon collégiale avec la
fonction publique territoriale enfin sur
euh la la pardon j'essaie de de ne pas
oublier de de questions euh
oui j'ai j'ai j'aiévoqué sur les enjeux
de protection fonctionnelle pardon mais
j'ai un peu répondu par antipation
effectivement moi le fait que c'est pas
un sujet bout pour moi de de pouvoir
envisager l'inversion de de de de la
charge mais je crois que la priorité
aujourd'hui mais évidemment c'est c'est
un sujet que je suis prêt à à poursuivre
et à approfondir c'est la bonne
application déjà de l'accès à la
protection fonctionnelle sont le
dispositif d'information qu'il faut
donner le ministre de l'Intérieur a mené
un travail sur ces questions là un
rapport lui a été remis donc là aussi
c'est un travail que je souhaite pouvoir
mener avec l'ensemble de mes collègues
au gouvernement pour apporter des
réponses solides et des réponses qui
concernent l'ensemble des des
fonctionnaires voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les les sénateurs les réponse
que je souhaitais apporter j'ai pas
répondu à l'ensemble de vos questions
mais j'aiessaie de le faire avec
sincérité et
engagement merci Monsieur le Ministre on
a bien compris le le cadre transversal
que vous fixiez et on
va explorer un peu tout ça avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale bien
sûr pour voir comment il traduit ça plus
spécifiquement dans son ministère on a
bien noté aussi qu'il y avait un projet
de loi attendu sur la protection
fonctionnelle à peu près quelle période
en fait j'ai j'ai évoqué un travail de
concertation sur un projet de loi pour
la fonction publique ou j'ai indiqué que
je souhaitais mener le travail de
concertation d'ici la fin de l'année
pour préparer un projet de loi ensuite
je ne peut pas préempter l'agenda
parlementaire mais certainement pour
2024 et donc dans ce cadre là nous
pourrions envisager d'avoir un chapitre
lié à la protection des agents et donc
je je soumettrai à la concertation et je
propose de pouvoir le le faire assez tôt
les articles qui ont été travaillés sur
la protection fonctionnelle à titre
conservatoire pour les en drroit ou sur
la capacité à porter plainte et donc je
je propose de vous les soumettre pour
avoir un travail de de concertation sur
ces questions là avant l'examen j'espère
en 2024 de ce projet de loi merci
monsieur le ministre si le président
buffet vous rajouter observation merci
monsieur le ministre pour ses
précisionsci vous prés a l'éducation
nationale sur
spécifique ENF des professeurs
d'éducation nationale en tout les cas
merci à vous merci beaucoup merci
oui pour les les collègues des deux
commissions nous avons une autre
audition à 18h des témoignages oui oui
bien sûr des témoignages
d'enseignants c'est ici c'est ça
clé moi jeis la
conférence